like that make a lot of us more wary of
restaurant ratings when eating ounces so
what steps can you take to make sure
your food is healthy sasha loftus spoke
with a high-rated restaurant in town
they shed some light on what they do to
keep things clean
ryan when you go out to eat it's not
always easy to know where your food is
coming from i spoke with the restaurant
owner today who says there are a lot of
other ways to protect yourself
with every sizzle snap and delicious
smell
it's easy to see this kitchen is clean
good quality food good service gaitanos
is a great place to get good healthy
meals with owner nick pal mary's
attention to detail this business is
very important to myself and to my
employees the henderson establishment
has had a steady a rating for decades
thanks to these efforts we actually
prepped this dish the day before so how
do you know if your favorite spot is
doing what it should every day you have
to feel like you have to have that
urgency that the health department is
going to be showing up the southern
nevada health district randomly inspects
restaurants and bars about every six
months
they then post the results with any
violations and an overall rating from a
to c online it goes from the back of the
house to the front of the house the
presentation of the dishes and
the personnel that you have it's a great
way to count on where your food is
coming from
so you can keep yourself and anyone
you're with
safe and happy if you can give someone
an actual experience to enjoy their meal
and and feel safe that's that's the
icing on the cake
the nick says it is also important to
just be observant when you eat out if
the tables floors or even the bathroom
isn't clean the kitchen probably isn't
either denise